all right well we have another possible
crime that donald trump or people around
him may have committed this one relates
to
what i call a revenge audit by the irs
this is um a couple things to understand
about this and one of course is that
what we have right now is something
circumstantial and suspicious that is
increasingly being
focused on trump and people around him
we don't yet know the full story but
this is uh salon has um
reported on
the uh reality
that both james comey and andrew mccabe
were subjected to
irs audits now these audits are very
rare and so to see two high-ranking fbi
officials
both
targeted by audits that have a one in
thirty thousand per year prevalence it
starts to raise some red flags former
fbi director james comey and his top
deputy andrew mccabe faced rare
intensive irs audits after investigating
former president donald trump according
to the new york times
comey whom trump fired in 2017
uh and mccabe who was similarly as to
comey fired after investigating trump
were selected for quote random audits
known as autopsy without the benefit of
death these are like the most invasive
audits out of about
153 million individual tax returns from
2017
only 5 000 people were selected for this
type of invasive audit each year now
we'll get to the math okay but the point
is these are extremely rare and for the
former fdi fbi director and the former
fbi deputy director to both be targeted
by these audits
it starts to be a little strange
comey mccabe and their spouses defied
the odds being selected for the audit
after being fired
the two men were selected for an irs
research program that uses compliance
research examinations to try to catch
tax cheats unlike typical audits these
audits force individuals to produce bank
records copies of checks receipts and
letters effectively recreating their
finances for the year in question this
takes months and often costs thousands
in accounting fees in in my experience
and i've not been audited but in talking
to accountants about it it's more than
thousands for this this this could be
tens of thousands
um the irs said in letters to both men
your federal income tax return for the
year shown above was selected at random
for a compliance research examination
we must examine randomly selected tax
returns to better understand tax
compliance and improve fairness of the
tax system
the minuscule chance of the two top fbi
officials being selected at random
raised questions about whether trump
appointees in the government or irs
purposely targeted them
lightning strikes and that's unusual and
that's what it's like being picked out
for one of these audits said irs
commissioner former irs commissioner
john koskinen the question is does
lightning then strike again in the same
area does it happen some people may see
that in their lives but most will not
trump spokeswoman has denied even
knowing about these audits okay so let's
do some math and i know the math is not
easy on this so i know that the math
people will tell me whether i'm wrong so
first first things first
if the odds of this audit is one in
thirty thousand or the odds are one in
thirty thousand
if you say what are the odds of two
specific people facing the same audit
you would get one in 900 million
assuming that every person is equally
likely to be audited that doesn't really
reflect the situation
uh in particular because you would
imagine
that a large number of my my guess is
that even if we believe the audits are
random
they're probably not being done for
people below a certain level of income
and that would probably be for two
reasons one that the amount that the irs
even stands to recover from someone who
might have cheated on their taxes if
they made 40 grand is very very low so
that's one thing and number two
the mechanisms that are often used to
avoid taxes or evade remember avoidance
and evasion are two different things
one's legal one is not um are much more
commonly used by people of higher
incomes so
it's it's not even the right number
because it's not the entire population
that is probably even really at risk for
this type of audit it's some subset of
that above a certain income level okay
but the other thing about this is that
there's the missing context of
well it's actually
four people because it's these two guys
and their spouses and i believe they
were in different years so if your risk
of this is one in thirty thousand each
year if we look over like the three year
period where trump could have
theoretically directed this or indicated
someone should do this then it's sort of
like three and thirty thousand it gets
complicated but i think what we have to
understand are a couple things one
this is very rare and two
to see both of the top fbi people
targeted with this
supposedly randomly
during a time when they were adversarial
to the president who appointed people to
the irs we know the president is one of
the most vindictive and childish
probably the most vindictive and
childish president that we've ever had
it is weird and so i'm not ready to say
trump directed this i'm not ready to say
it was even necessarily
within trump's purview
but
it's strange enough that it should be
investigated and one of the things we
have to remember also is like imagine
that it was something trump did in
theory this is a federal crime
uh but
trump really exposed how easy it is
to just ignore all of the checks and
balances on people in positions of power
and uh if this was a retaliatory irs
audit whoever directed it aside from
whoever did it
should be investigated should be charged
if that's what that's what happened but
trump flouted all sorts of different
norms and checks and balances and at
least for now there have not really been
any consequences so we learned that the
framers
set up some checks and balances but they
clearly assumed no one would ever
flout them that's flout
uh to the degree that donald trump did
and so how strong are those checks and
balances
if they can be ignored with essentially
no consequences we will continue to get
answers to that one of our sponsors is
better help the customized online
therapy service that offers video phone
and live chat with your therapist you
don't even have to see anyone on camera
if you don't want to you fill out a
questionnaire to help assess your
specific needs and then you're matched
with a licensed therapist in under 48
hours you can schedule secure video and
phone sessions you can exchange
unlimited messages with your therapist
and you can request a new therapist at
any time for any reason at no charge
talking to a therapist doesn't mean
there's something wrong with you it
means you're doing something for
yourself and for your wellness you get
your car serviced you work out you see
the doctor to prevent physical illness
and disease
therapy is the same thing anyone can
benefit from it i think it's very
important join the two million plus
people who have taken charge of their
mental health with better help get ten
percent off your first month at
betterhelp.com pacman the link is down
below